the circle of competences the area in
which certain kinds of Industries for
example I can understand a future
economics of other kinds of Industries I
have to know where that the perimeter of
that circle is now over the years I may
be able to enlarge the circle somewhat
but the circle never gets to be
all-encompassing Tom Watson senior who
built IBM said I'm no genius but I'm
smart as spots and I stay around those
spots well he was talking about a circle
of confidence you know my partner
Charlie says you know it's wonderful to
have a IQ of 180 as long as you don't
think it's 200 and I have seen all kinds
of very very smart people a
self-destruct one way or another in
business or particularly in in the stock
market and they stray outside of their
circle of competence just because they
know they're very very smart but that
doesn't mean they know everything and
defining what your game is where where
you're going to have an edge is
enormously important and I think both my
partner Charlie and I have gotten
reasonably good at that over the years
hey seven Carmichael and I make these
videos because run into business is hard
and waking up every day getting the work
when you're all by yourself is hard and
the thing that saved me that continues
to inspire me motivate me give me hope
inspiration ideas is looking at the
stories of people who've done a lot more
than me and I learn strategies I get
motivation and it gets me to believe in
myself to go off and attack the day and
so I hope this video inspires you to do
the same as well so today let's learn
the billionaire advice to become
successful enjoy
rule number two is be a real
entrepreneur with Jeff Bezos if you want
to be an entrepreneur
the most important thing is to be
customer obsessed so don't satisfy your
customers
figure out how to absolutely Delight
them that is the number one thing
whoever your customers are
passion you have got to have some
passion for the arena
that you're going to develop and work in
because otherwise you're going to be
competing against people who do have
compassion for that and they're going to
build better products and services you
can't be a mercenary you have to be a
missionary missionaries build better
products and services they always win
the mercenaries are just trying to make
money
and paradoxically the missionaries
always end up making more money to pick
something that you actually have a
genuine passion for you have to take
risk
you have to be willing to take risk if
you aren't going to take risk if you
come up with a business idea there's
there's no risk there
you're probably
you know it's probably already being
done those ideas are already being done
they're being done well by many many
people so you've got to have something
that might not work
and so you have to accept that your
business is going to be in many ways an
experiment and it might fail and that's
okay that's what risk is the good news
is in Amazon we still take risks all the
time and we encourage it and we talk
about failure we should be feeling our
failures have to grow with the company
we need big failures if we're going to
be moving the needle we need to have you
know billion dollar scale failures and
if we're not we're not swinging we're
not swinging hard enough rule number
three is get great at selling with Mark
Cuban if you come up with an idea where
you say I can make dollar bills for 50
cents
would you go out and raise money or
would you just go out and sell it
you just go out and do it you know and
and that's what you have to do and look
we all go through that fear factor of do
I quit my job do I can I do this
um can I can I do this and what happens
next the one thing I I know with 100
certainty and what I would tell myself
is
if I can sell
and become a better and better
salesperson and be great at selling
I'm always going to be successful
whether I'm working for myself
or if the company that I started just
didn't work I'll give you an example
um out of Indiana before I went down to
Dallas I needed to start something and
um I decided that everybody drank milk
and I found this product powdered milk
that was cheaper and everybody needed to
save money and I was going to go out
there and sell it
um because it was cheaper now it didn't
taste quite as good
and so what I've but I went out there to
try to sell it
failed miserably but I learned
how to make the sales effort even when
things weren't going right I learned
that the rejection was every no got me
closer to a yes that not every product
was perfect but I could take those same
skills even in failure and translate
them so that what I learned selling
garbage bags door to door what I learned
from selling powdered milk that was
awful what I learned from selling local
area networks at micro Solutions all
those things
accumulated and I I got better at
selling so I always knew you know people
always say to me if you lost everything
what would you do
I can sell
I can sell and it's not about selling
ice to Eskimos it's not about you know
convincing people to do this selling is
always about helping selling is always
about understanding the person you're
talking to and what their needs are and
if someone can help me
make my life easier yeah people you know
now with employees people always say
well like what's the definition of a
great employee
someone who can reduce the stress of
those around them and it's the same
thing what's the definition of a great
salesperson someone who can reduce the
stress of their sales people and if in
looking at your company and looking at
your your life and looking at your goals
if you're able to go out there and
recognize that
whether it works or doesn't work you're
putting yourself in a position where
you're helping somebody not convincing
somebody but and you're reducing their
stress
you're gonna you're gonna be okay it's
gonna work out and you know that's the
confidence I I've built in myself that
wasn't necessarily always there
um
but I learned that if I try to help if I
reduce people's stress good things can
happen also to make sure you're actually
taking action after watching this video
I've designed a special free worksheet
just for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number four is take big
Chances with Elon Musk I don't really
like risk for risk's sake or anything
it's and I do think that um
other things are are very risky with a
low chance of success but if you want to
try to come up with an introvert
breakthrough that's kind of that's going
to be how it is
anything which is significantly
Innovative is going to come with a
significant risk of failure
um and um but you know if you've got to
take big chances in order for the
potential for a big positive outcome
um and um
you know just if and if I mean if the
outcome is exciting enough then then
taking a big risk is worthwhile yeah
it's really
our approach it but but then once
executing down a path I actually do my
absolute best to reduce uh risk you know
because or to improve another way of
saying to improve the probability of
success because uh when you try to do
something that is very
um very risky
you have to spend a lot of effort trying
to reduce that risk as you Embark down
that path I mean when
um when I started SpaceX the I thought
the odds of success were very low
um I thought we're most likely fail but
I thought well
we should give it a try nonetheless rule
number five is hustle with Sarah Blakely
I feel like hustle is the willingness to
work really really hard and then also
your willingness to get the job done
like
um kind of navigating and doing what it
takes and
um
and so I I yeah I've there's so much
about my journey where I was like I am
not going to let the outcome or My
Success be contingent on other people as
much as I can control it help it
navigate it I'm going to so
um
so yeah in the beginning especially
still now I mean obviously I'm hustling
I'm like at the at this where I am now
and I'm running around the airport
asking people to follow me on Instagram
you know uh I just feel like it's innate
in me also to a degree
um but the uh in the beginning ex like
there's a few examples that come to mind
you mentioned that I paid my I called my
friends and asked them to go buy Spanx
and I wrote everybody checks and sent
them a check
um because I needed to drive momentum
and I had no money to advertise so I'm
like this product's gonna sit on the
shelves so I needed to get
people to go in and buy it I also when I
went into the stores I realized very
quickly that my product was in the
sleepiest part of the department store
it was back in the corner and nobody was
going there so then I immediately
um uh went to Target and I bought
envelope dividing dividers that you put
on your home desk and I ran around
Neiman Marcus and put them at every
register and I put Spanx in them and
then I walked away
and
Neiman's has like impeccable visual
rules and regulations and um and I did
that because I had to get my product out
of the department and because I did that
women in shoes started buying Spanx and
women in contemporary and and um those
decisions made such a big difference and
by the time somebody figured out that
nobody else had approved it because you
know everybody thought somebody else
approved it
um it was so successful that the head of
Neiman's was like whatever this girl's
doing let her keep doing it rule number
six is shift your thinking with Ray
dalio Once you have a fear
that you might be wrong
but you have still the audaciousness and
courage to go forward
you're a lot smarter
than the person who thinks they know
there's a there's a quote that Jefferson
said
he who knows he knows not is closer to
the truth than he whose mind is filled
with falsehoods and and so when you know
that and with and then with your
character and your determination you go
forward the smartest people I know
are the most humble
it what the more you learn the more you
realize oh I'm eager to take in so
that's right
um but back on your audience
I I think your audience ranges from um
you know there's a wide range that you
have in your audience
and I would say that there are many
people in your audience
who can plan
for a simple lifestyle that can be
wonderful sometimes we acquire these
needs that aren't at anywhere near as
big as as we make them out to be
um you know
um do you have a bed to sleep in do you
have food to eat do you have basic
health care
okay if you start to think okay what are
my needs that I really need and I'm okay
and how can I make Provisions for those
needs
then once you've got that in your mind
you're you're free okay you you can go
beyond that that you may say listen oh I
can do that for a year or two years or a
month or whatever but you I think we
visualize too much the things that we're
used to one of the good things about
this exercise is that you can bring it
brings you back to basics you can be
brought to Basics and like I'm saying if
you have a bed to sleep in
and you've got food
and so on and you have those Basics and
and good relationships with people who
care about you and basic health care
so if you budget for that and you figure
how do you have it maybe it isn't in the
luxurious place you're in maybe it's in
the country and so on once you visualize
that and you get that down in your head
and you say oh I can get that
then your stress will disappear because
you as you visualize that in many ways
that's a happy life it doesn't take a
lot to there's stimulation there's
nature there's relationships these
fundamental
wonderful things the most important
things can be obtained and so for many
of you I think if you look at that and
you budget for that I'm seeing a number
of people
who are
um going broke
uh and and I've watched this over many
years
and really it's just the adjustment
process when that once they get to that
point where ah you know they have they
get settled
they're fine
it's the ambiguity it's the worry it's
the stress so if you do that from the
beginning and you have that that played
out in your head then you know
everything from there you can play with
and it's your it's uh icing on the cake
so I want to emphasize you can budget
for that you can look at that find that
scenario find what that looks like so
that you know you've got it down then
you know you're safe once you've got
safe everything beyond that is luxury
and rule number seven the last one
before some very special bonus Clips is
have a long-term focus with Mark
Zuckerberg what do you think the three
keys to your success are
well I think a lot of it goes back to
those values right I mean the values
often come from the founder the person
running the company so I think I believe
those things probably the most strongly
of people at the company
um yeah move fast be bold right
um focus on impact and I think
um
you know I think long-term focus is is a
really important part of this and we've
had a lot of opportunities to optimize
for the shorter term whether it's in
selling the company or doing different
products that would have benefited Us in
the short term but not optimized for the
long-term impact and um and I just think
you know opportunities like this don't
come around that often so when you get
one I feel like you almost have a duty
to see it through and build it to be
what it can be
most important thing is you have to
there's two sides that really sort of
the intellectual or mental side you have
to pick a business that has a niche you
have to have a reason to succeed you
have to be something like we were doing
say Japan can beat Germany in
manufacturing of this type of a product
that was the niche really and then on
that you just have to have a total and
complete passion because there's going
to be so many dark moments uh you know I
think it the dark moments are true for
any uh entrepreneur or any startup
company I'm sure that you talk to Steve
Jobs and apple you'd see many many dark
dark moments ours happened to last a
little longer than most of them but you
really emotionally have to be prepared
for those dark moments I think every
entrepreneur I've ever spoken to which
would Echo that yeah that there are
adult moments everything's on the line
that's the life of an entrepreneur and
so you're going to be into it you better
be prepared for that you're unusually
fearless and willing to go in the face
of other people telling you something
that's crazy and I know a lot of pretty
crazy people you still stand out uh
where does that come from or how do you
think about making a decision when
everyone tells you this is a crazy idea
or where do you get the internal
strength to do that
well first of all I'd say I actually
think I I think I feel feel fear quite
strongly
um so it's not as though
I just have the absence of fear I feel
quite strongly
um but there were just times when
something is important enough you've
believe it enough that you you do it in
spite of the fear So speaking of
important things like people shouldn't
think I I I I should people should think
well I feel fear about this and
therefore I shouldn't do it
um it's normal to be to feel fear like
you'd have to definitely something
mentally wrong if you didn't feel fair
so you just feel it and let the
importance of it drive you to do it
anyway yeah you know actually something
that can be helpful is fatalism uh to
some degree it's just accept the
probabilities
um then that diminishes fear uh so
um we're starting SpaceX I thought the
odds of success were less than 10
percent
um and I just accepted that actually
probably I would just lose lose
everything
um
but that maybe would make some progress
if we could just move the ball forward
even if we died Maybe
some other company could pick up the
Baton and move and keep moving it
Forward
um so that would still do some good same
with Tesla I thought the odds of a car
company succeeding were extremely low
there are lots of times especially in
the early days uh that were that were
very very difficult I think I think the
most difficult thing experience I had
was in 1990 when Oracle had its had its
only lost quarter in history and we've
been in business for 20 years of the 20
years we lost money one quarter and we
had a very difficult time
um because we had almost we doubled our
sales virtually every year for 10 years
nine nine out of ten years 10 out of 11
years it was really quite an amazing run
where the fastest growing company in
history still were still are the you
know the fastest growing company in
history over a long period of time
and
suddenly we'd hit a wall we would reach
a billion dollars in revenue and we were
having serious management problems all
over the place
and the people who are running the
company the billion dollar company were
the same people that run the company
when we were a 50 million dollar company
120 at the size
and I hadn't had had an incredible sense
of loyalty to those people who'd worked
with me to build Oracle
and it was a very painful realization in
1990 that I was going to have to change
the management team that that the
company had outgrown
the management uh that
people who are good at running a 50
million dollar company are not
necessarily those are the same skills so
they're just different not one is better
or worse they're just entirely different
skill set in running a 50 million dollar
company than a billion dollar company
and uh
both skill sets are rare and precious
but we needed a different group of
managers and virtually the entire
management team had to be replaced and
that means I had to ask people who I'd
worked with for a decade to leave I had
to fire people
uh and that was the most difficult
the most the most difficult thing I had
to do in in business asking them yeah
a bunch of people too
leave Oracle but I had no choice
I never either ask them to leave Oracle
or everyone would have to leave Oracle
because it wouldn't be any Oracle left
so it was in that sense it was a simple
choice
it was uh
thousands of people worked at Oracle uh
they deserve the best leadership we
could find uh and
my primary I mean my primary
responsibility was to the company and
all of the staff you know all of our
shareholders and all of our customers
and uh therefore I had to choose
and if I couldn't make that decision
then I had to go there's a Latin
expression which I think is great I love
it it was in a now very old movie called
The Dead Poet Society
but the line of the movie was Carpe Diem
seize the day
the opportunities are there but you got
to reach out and pick them up
you've got to grab at them
some of you may have already done that
at the U in your classes in other
students that you met in your
extracurricular activities but grab them
don't be afraid to make a mistake
because you know what you can do if you
grab the wrong one
drop it and pick up another one
it's okay seize the day
I think back of all of the the the luck
but also the times that were in front of
me to seize the day
I don't know what got me to drop out of
business school and come to Microsoft my
parents thought I was a whack job
neither one of them graduated college
and they thought this was really a wild
idea
I was lucky I seized the day
Microsoft one day some guys fly in from
from IBM
and all of a sudden we figure out we
could actually provide all the software
they need for this thing that became the
personal computer
people Bill Paul they had the wisdom to
seize the day when that opportunity
presented itself
And yet when you think of all the
opportunities when I think back of all
the opportunities I've had the one that
was most important
was an opportunity I got in 1969.
sitting in my junior high school class I
was in a public Junior High not very
stimulated at the time and over the
loudspeaker
they said that well private high school
in our area that I'd never heard of was
giving scholarship tests that weekend
I told my mother I wanted to take him
she said that's fine as long as you get
a scholarship because we can't afford to
send you there
but that's really where I got switched
down switched on in math switched on
personally energized in a way that never
never could be turned back and I am very
thankful for that opportunity
yes there's a lot of luck in opportunity
but there's a lot of seizing the day
and I encourage you all to reach out and
Carpe Diem really seize the
opportunities that are in front of you
it's never too late to get started it's
never too late to say yes it's never too
late to start to chase down your dreams
the thing that you got inside you it's
never too late we create these stories
for ourselves as I am
too old to get started I am too acts
like fill in the blank of whatever
excuse you've got for not taking action
[Music]
it's just a story
you're just afraid and the only thing
you're missing is momentum
it's never too late
I remember when I started my business I
thought I was too young you know
I was 19 years old I was telling the
people who
were experts in science and I sucked at
science and they were two to three times
my age and I had phds and I thought I
was too young they'd never take me
seriously and that was one of the things
that really held back the growth of my
business was
just my limiting belief that I was too
young
and I talked to people all the time and
you have people who say they're too
young
and then instantly they become too old
like but when are you over the right age
you know you're too young to do it then
you're too old to do it when were you
actually ever the right age when have
you ever said you know what I'm the
right age to do this thing
right we never we never do that it's
always just the fear talking
and so you have to step up you have to
step out you have to say yes
and you have to get started people ask
me all the time was it too late to get
started on YouTube I was at a conference
I was speaking at this weekend and
is it too late Evan is it too did I miss
the boat
kidding me
first off YouTube is growing like crazy
second the the education on YouTube is
still pretty low there's so many people
going and there's still so few people
who are creating good quality education
look at whatever field you're in it's
probably even less
and third even if YouTube does go away
at some point
there's gonna be something else
people's attention is not going offline
anytime soon it's only going to increase
if YouTube goes away something else will
will come up and your ability to speak a
message to a camera is a skill set that
will serve you for life of course it's
not too late
it's just your fear talking
go up Big Dreams and big goals and big
Ambitions are possible
there's so few worlds where it actually
is too late right and like if you're 70
years old and you want to play you know
in the NBA Athletics is the easy one to
go to then that's it's too late you know
you're not going to go you're not going
to be a professional NBA player sorry
but could you be involved in the world
of could you start a great podcast
around it a YouTube channel around it or
be an agent or like infinite number of
things in that world of course and
chances are most of your goals dreams
things that you want to do
are not tied to anything physical where
there's going to be a significant
decline right like what are the things
what do you want to do what are your
goals it's people who have done it at a
much older age than you
so how do we unlock it how do we start
to make
that momentum actually happen in your
life step number one
get really clear on what you want
what do you want what are your goals
what do you what do you want to do
what's the voice inside your head that
is telling you I wish I could do this
thing I really want to do this thing
right like getting really clear because
I meet a lot of entrepreneurs and you
know that you're capable of more and you
know you want to have a bigger impact
and you know that
that you don't want to stay stuck here
but you don't know what the thing looks
like you know it's not as clear of what
you want to do you just know that you're
stuck and you're capable of more
well you definitely don't have the whole
thing planned out but what's the next
step
just getting clear on what you want the
next step to be
can make a big big big big big big big
difference
because it gives you some clarity
whether it's even the perfect I mean
it's not going to be the perfect step
don't worry about being the perfect step
it probably won't be the right the right
step it's a step
and in taking a step you learn a lot and
you make a lot of mistakes you make a
ton of mistakes and you figure things
out I remember when I first got my phone
I was recording and I I did this video
and I was I was so proud of the video
and then I realized I captured the whole
thing in slow motion mode
the audio was terrible you can't use it
I couldn't use it like oh it was so good
slow motion mode you just you're gonna
make mistakes at the beginning that's
okay but what's the next step getting
some clarity over what that next step
should be is really important part two
is then go get some Heroes
it could be a mentor who you can
actually talk to and learn from but
Heroes
and when I say Heroes I mean people
who've done the thing that you want to
do
whenever I feel less than whenever I
feel like I can't do it whenever I feel
not good enough I Look to people who
have done it
and I realized that they have done it
with less resources less money less time
less
skills and what I have right now Your
Heroes the people who you love look up
to respect the most they did it they
accomplished with less than what you
have right now
and if they can do it you can do it too
and the whole point of that is a push to
start taking action it's not to say oh
well I suck I can never be Oprah Winfrey
or whoever go look at Oprah's story and
see where she came from and see how how
poor she was and see what her upbringing
was and imagine being Oprah imagine
having a terrible upbringing uh you know
being raped early on having tons of
violence in the family
bouncing from home to home
being so poor that she couldn't afford
clothes and her grandmother would so
address for her out of a potato bag like
imagine you're going to school in a
potato bag
that your grandmother sewed together
because you didn't have enough money to
actually get real close
can you imagine
how bad is your life compared to that
how bad was your upbringing compared to
that
right to go from where she started to
where she's at
what's your excuse
and again it's not meant to be a
negative like oh you're right I'm so
hard on myself I suck no it's more like
well that's what's possible
as soon as you get over the store you're
telling yourself that's what's possible
if she could do it
from that upbringing why can't you why
can't I
and anytime I feel like I can't do it
that that's what I default back to it's
like look at your Heroes look at where
they started look at where they came
from and chances are Your Heroes already
started with less than what you already
have right now and so surrounding
yourself with them
can give you the hope and the feeling
like it is possible if you feel like
you're too old for something then
surround yourself with entrepreneurs who
started who are way older than you
look at people who have started and they
started I don't know how old you are you
know people say I I'm 24 years old is it
too late to get started
but on every age people feel it's too
late
so surround yourself with the stories of
people who started when they're older
gives you the inspiration to go to make
to create
Island number three is come back to
service think about service think about
who you're doing this for this is this
is bigger than you it's not just about
you
so who are you going to help
whenever it's just about you whenever
it's you're doing something for just
selfish reasons
you'll never put in the same amount of
work as if you feel like you're
responsible to somebody else this is
where a lot of entrepreneurs struggle in
starting their own business because when
you had a job you had a boss and your
boss would tell you what to do if you
didn't show up to a meeting you'd be in
trouble you know so you'd show up for
other people but you don't show up for
yourself
we just won't show up for ourselves as
much people show up for other people so
the way to hack it is to feel like what
you're doing is actually serving other
people
and if you're an entrepreneur land you
can think about the customers you're
going to serve the people who will
consume your content or buy your
products or service and the life
changing impact that you're going to
have and feel it and connect to that if
you don't have a business yet or that's
not your ambition just think about your
message to your kids
think about the message to your family
think about the message of the people
around you is your message to your kids
current or future
you know what it's too late
you when you get an idea just tell
yourself that you can't do it
you know is that going to be your
message to your of course not
but it's your message to yourself
and the people closest to you will model
much more what you do
your actions your beliefs more than what
you say
you could tell them believe in yourself
you're not it's not too late go ahead go
do it you can make this happen but when
they see you sitting on the sidelines
telling yourself that you're too old and
you can't do it that's the behavior
they're going to model
so if you're not going to do it for
yourself
that's not enough of a oomph to get you
out of the bed and actually creating
your thing then think about who you're
serving today
think about the people you're going to
help
people who by you showing up is going to
have an impact on their lives
it's not too late to start
it's never too late to start
your life
could be so different
if you woke up and started doing a thing
that was in your heart it's not going to
work out at the beginning you're going
to have a lot of failures you're going
to have a lot of laughs you're going to
have a lot of struggles as you get going
but holy cow your life can be
dramatically different one year two
years five years from today
if you just decided you know what
I'm just tired of staying stuck
I'm tired of coming up with excuses
I'm tired of playing small
it's time
I need this for myself
I need this for my family
I need this for the people who I'm going
to serve and help
it's time
time
it's your time
let's see what you can make
foreign
video I want to celebrate you most
people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you're different you are
special believe Nation you made it here
all the way to the end and I love you so
it's a special celebration if you put a
hashtag believe down in the comments
Below on this video I will showcase you
and celebrate you somewhere on the
screen in a future video because you are
awesome to master the Habits of Highly
Successful People check the video right
there next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there well I read a lot less these days
than I used to when I was a kid I was
read all the time I mean mostly
subscribe to Scientific periodicals the
The Daily News I find to be a lot of
noise and just very negative seem to be
trying to answer the question